all right joining us right here in the
spin room the man in the middle of the
stage tonight Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis Governor how are you good to
see you good to see you you know I
thought and we she was saying that Laura
was saying that she felt you got
stronger throughout the night but I
thought your open was particularly
strong and and it's a message that most
Americans believe this is a nation in
Decline then you went into American
first policies then you talked about
Ukraine you know we're not securing our
borders why are we why are we spending
all of that money when Europe won't even
step up yeah look I think that the
nation's in Decline but this declines a
choice and we're going to make this
Choice over the next 18 months we can
reverse the decline we can restore
America I think it's similar to the late
1970s when Jimmy Carter was President a
lot of people said it was an age of
limits America wasn't going to be able
to be great again and uh Ronald Reagan
had a different idea so that's just I
think what the average American is
seeing in their own daily lives and so
in some respects we can point out all
the bad things and there's a lot of bad
things but I am optimistic that it can
be done you know why because we did it
in Florida everything I laid out in
Florida we accomplished and the state is
boomed we can do the same thing for the
U.S okay so that was a big part of your
theme tonight this is Florida
2018. you had a pretty close race I was
down in Florida governor in that race as
you know and and then you come back and
four years later you win by a record
million and a half votes that would be I
would think validation for your
governing skills for the state
um and you kept talking about I will not
let you down explain well look I think
that there's a lot of people that get
elected they over promise under deliver
when when times get really tough uh
there's a lot of people that aren't
going to stay stay in the fire and what
I did in Florida particularly during
covid making sure the kids can be in
school protecting everyone's business
your kids were back in school in August
of 2020 right and and I got pilloried
for that but but when I Stand My Ground
for you you can take that to the bank I
am not going to back down uh I've taken
on the left and the Democrats in the
media and we've beaten all those people
and I think that when in Florida part of
the reason I did so well is because
people they knew where I stood and they
knew look if the governor says he's
going to do something he's going to do
it he doesn't just make idle promises
when he says it'll do it so I think
that's the same thing as president I'm
campaigning on a bold agenda but I am
not saying anything that I don't intend
to follow through with and so when I
talk about using the military to take on
the drug cartels because they're killing
tens of thousands of our citizens we
have every right to do it I'm going to
do it I'm not just going to get into
office and say forget about it so so
people should know that Now's the Time
to get it done I think our country if we
get another four years of this I don't
know if we could bring it hope we
recover I really don't so I'd be
negligent if I didn't ask you I asked
this question to Donald Trump and it was
about I said you and Governor DeSantis I
said because you guys were friends he
did support you and and I supported him
I mean I you know we I support him in 16
obviously and then in 2020 they really
relied on me you know to do a lot in
Florida I raised more money than him
than any elected official in the country
I mean I raise you know 10 15 million
dollars and we worked really hard to
make sure the Florida election ran
really well you know we have the best
election Integrity in the country in
Florida by the way because there were
two points when it wasn't the best right
and we got it done and so that's really
important and so and you know the thing
is is I mean I know he attacks me a lot
now but that's just you know when I
started to to get Steam for re-election
you know he came out and started dinging
me that's fine
um I don't think he should do that but
it is what it is but I do when I did ask
him what happened he did say I supported
him he fell to his disloyal what did you
ever respond to that no here's the thing
Sean I'm loyal to my family the
Constitution and the Lord Our God I work
with other politicians to advance a
common agenda but nobody's entitled to
be endorsed or supported you've got to
earn that and I would mind you you know
he started attacking me before I even
got in before I even got re-elected he
started to do it so that's fine but at
the end of the day we're gonna we're
gonna do what we need to do let's ask
about the the controversial issue of
abortion and you signed a six-week Bill
the heartbeat bill
um now look I I don't think anybody
really anticipated Roe v Wade would be
overturned right it would have been a
matter of loss most Republican justices
have let us down over the years and so
even when Dobbs was pending a lot of
people said Kavanaugh are they going to
do it and so so they did do it though
and they deserve credit but it's an
issue that went back to the states do
you support this more as a state issue
or do you think it should be Federal
legislation so what I've said is uh one
our heartbeat bill I am proud of it was
is the right thing to do the reality in
our country right now is is advancing
protections for life is bottom up that's
just the reality based on kind of the
the demographics and the public opinion
and whatnot and so you're not going to
have Wisconsin do what Texas has done
just like Iowa is going to be different
than New Hampshire that's just where we
find ourselves and so you know I'm going
to stay a state issue or should
federally there be a standard well look
if there is something to prevent like
late-term abortions that's been done
before I mean obviously you know as a
pro-life president I'm going to support
you pointed that out too and I think
this is key there is an extreme radical
left-wing position oh the government it
should not get uh in the room with a
patient and and a woman and okay so that
that position basically is you can have
an abortion up until the moment of birth
and they will not a Democrat politician
if you ask them when does the child get
protection nine months they will not
give of an answer when we point this out
the corporate media the liberal media
right they run interference for the
Democrats so they attack us for being
pro-life and then they go to the
Democrats and act like the Democrats
aren't taking very very extreme
positions I was glad you did fire those
two prosecutors that refused to do their
job I thought that went over really well
uh we need that nationally I mean these
cities are War zones in some of the
places and it's all because of leftist
ideology any place this ideology has
been put in those cities are failing I'm
going to clean it up as president uh
you're looking forward to Gavin Newsom
yeah it's going to be fun we got to get
we got to get the date and got a venue
and everything date we're working on the
venue part that's really we have one
little piece of the puzzle left that I
think we'll get it done I didn't want to
bother them this week with all the the
bad weather and issues yeah yeah great
to see you guys thank you thank you
appreciate you being on hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else